can you take on the impossible task and
give a brief history of programming
languages from your perspective so I
guess you could say programming
languages started probably in what the
late 40s or something like that people
used to program computers by basically
putting in zeros and ones using
something like switches on a console and
then or maybe holes and paper tapes
something like that so extremely tedious
awful whatever and so I think the first
programming languages were relatively
crude assembly languages where people
would basically write a program that
would convert mnemonics like add a DD
into whatever the bit pattern was it
corresponding to an add instruction and
they'd do the clerical work of figuring
out where things were so you could put a
name on a location in a program and the
assembler would figure out where that
correspond to when the thing was all put
together and dropped into memory and
that early on and this would be the late
40s and very early 50s there were
assemblers written for the various
machines that people used you may have
seen in the paper just a couple days ago
Tony Burt died he did this thing in
Manchester called the called auto code a
language for China knew only by name but
it sounds like it was a flavor of
assembly language sort of a little
higher in some ways um and it replaced
on languages Alan Turing wrote which you
put in zeros and ones but you put him in
backwards order because that was a
hardware word gracious that's right yeah
yeah that's right backwards so assembly
languages learn let's call that the
early 1950s and so every different
flavor of computer has its own assembly
language so the EDSAC head it's in a
manchester head it's and the IBM
whatever 70 90 or 704 or whatever hits
and so on so everybody had their own
assembly line assembly languages have a
few commands additions subtraction then
branching or some kind of than type of
situation right they have exactly in
their simplest form at least one
instruction per or one assembly language
instruction per instruction in the
machines repertoire
and so you have to know the Machine
intimately to be able to write programs
in it and if you write an assembly
language program for one kind of machine
and then you say jeez it's nice I'd like
a different machine start over okay so
very bad and so what happened in the
late 50s was people realize you could
play this game again and you could move
up a level in writing or creating
languages that were closer to the way
the real people might think about how to
write code and were I guess arguably
three or four at that time period there
was Fortran which came from IBM which
was formula translation meant to make it
easy to do scientific and engineering
computation is know that formula
translation that's what I stood for yeah
I was COBOL which is the common business
oriented language that Grace Hopper and
others worked on which was named
business kinds of tasks there was a well
which was mostly meant to describe
algorithmic computations I guess you
could argue basic was in there somewhere
I think it's just a little later and so
all of those moved the level up and so
they were closer to what you and I might
think of as we were trying to write a
program and they were focused on
different domains Fortran for formula
translation engineering computations
let's say COBOL for business that kind
of thing and still used today
Fortran probably oh yeah COBOL too but
the deal was that once you moved up that
level then you let's call it Fortran you
had a language that was not tied to a
particular kind of hardware because a
different compiler would compile for
different kind of hardware and that
meant two things
it meant you only had to write the
program once which is very important and
it meant that you could in fact if you
were a random engineer physicist
whatever you could write that program
yourself you didn't have to hire a
programmer to do it for you might not be
as good as you'd get through a
programmer but it was pretty good and so
it democratized and made much more
broadly available the ability to write
code so it puts the power of programming
into the hands of people like you yeah
anybody who wants to who under is
willing to invest some time in learning
a programming language and is not then
tied to a particular kind of computer
and then in the 70s you get system
programming languages of which C is the
survivor and what is system programming
language in programs that programming
languages that would take on the kinds
of things that would necessary to write
so-called system programs things like
text editors or assemblers or compilers
or operating systems themselves those
kinds of things
and fortunately feature-rich they have
to be able to do a lot of stuff a lot of
memory management access processes and
all that kind of stuff they a little
processing it's a different flavor what
they're doing they're much more in touch
with the actual machine in a but in a
positive way that is you can talk about
memory in a more controlled way you can
talk about the different data types that
the Machine supports and underway there
and more ways to structure and organize
data and so the system programming
languages there was a lot of effort in
that and call it the late 60s early 70s
C is I think the only real survivor of
that and then what happens after that
you get things like object-oriented
programming languages because as you
write programs in a language like C at
some point scale gets to you and it's
too hard to keep track of the pieces and
there's no guardrails or training wheels
or something like that to prevent you
from doing bad things
so C++ comes out of that tradition it's
and then it took off from there I mean
there's also a parallel slightly
parallel track with a little bit of
functional stuff of Lisp and so on but I
guess from that point it's just an
explosion of languages it was a java
story there's the JavaScript there's all
the stuff that the cool kids these days
are doing with rust and all that they
don't
you